أمريكا تستجدي الصين
وتحاول ثنيها عن دعم حليفها الروسي
لكن هل ترضخ بكين لهذه المطالب؟.
. رعب غربي من انقطاع الغاز الروسي
وتركيز على الجزائر فهل تستطيع الجزائر
أن تعوض العجز الأوروبي
وتكون وسيلة لإنقاذهم؟
وبريطانيا تدخل خط المساعدات
العسكرية لأوكرانيا،..
الولايات المتحدة توقف تجارب صواريخها
فهل هو خوفا من موسكو أم تأجيلاً للمشاكل؟..
.دول البلطيق تقطع استيرادها غاز موسكو
وماكرون يتهم بوتين مجددا،
كوريا الشمالية تطلق التحذيرات لجارتها
الجنوبية فهل تندلع حرب بين الشمال والجنوب؟
ليبيا تطلب مساعدة الشيشان لطرق باب بوتين،،
موسكو تحشد لسيطرة تامة
على إقليم دونباس، وزيلنيسكي
ينتظر لقاء بوتين...
أوروبا تعلق تعاونها مع روسيا
في مجال الفضاء بسبب الأزمة الأوكرانية..
وروسيا تبحث التعاون مع الصين
في قطاع الفضاء بعد العقوبات الغربية
(صداقة متينة)
الأوروبيون حذروا الصينيين من أن أي دعم
لروسيا في النزاع الأوكراني
"سيؤدي إلى إلحاق ضرر جسيم
بسمعة الصين" في أوروبا.
لترد بكين على مطالب الغرب
بأن تتوقف عن دعم موسكو بالأسلحة
أو الاقتصاد أو تخفيف العقوبات الغربية،،،
حيث قالت الصين إنها ستواصل التجارة
الطبيعية مع روسيا دون السعي للالتفاف
على العقوبات الغربية المفروضة على موسكو.
وأكد مدير الإدارة الأوروبية
بوزارة الخارجية الصينية، وانغ لوتونغ:
الصين ليست طرفا في النزاع في أوكرانيا"
وتلعب دورا مهما في تنمية التجارة العالمية،
وبالتالي فهي تعارض باستمرار
استخدام العقوبات.
(دعم بريطاني)
مسؤول بريطاني رفيع يقول:
"الأوكرانيون طلبوا المساعدة عبر إمدادهم
بأسلحة فتاكة من أجل منطقة البحر الأسود،
لدينا قائمة بما يحتاجونه،
ونحاول قدر الإمكان تقديمها إليهم".
وأعلنت المملكة المتحدة مؤخراً
أنّها تستعد لإرسال 6000 صاروخ
إضافي مضاد للدبابات، وبذلك يصل العدد
الإجمالي للأسلحة البريطانية إلى 10000.
بينما حذّر وزير الدفاع الروسي سيرغي شويغو،
في وقتٍ سابق، دول "الناتو" من تبعات
تزويد أوكرانيا بمقاتلات وأنظمة دفاع جوي،
مؤكّداً أنّه إذا تمّ تنفيذ ذلك، فإنّ بلاده "
ستردّ بشكل مناسب".
(دول أوروبا تستنجد بالجزائر)
تحسبا لخسارة الغاز الروسي أوروبا
تتخرك باتجاه الجزائر
سعيا للحصول على تعهدات بزيادة
ضخ الغاز الجزائري لأوروبا
الجزائر لا يمكنها "تعويض التراجع في واردات
الغاز الروسية" منفردةً، وأكدت بأنه
يمكنها أن تقدم مليارين أو ثلاثة مليارات
متر مكعب إضافية كحد أقصى
وتعتبر الجزائر ثالث مورد لأوروبا بالغاز
بعد كل من روسيا والنرويج
الجزائر بإمكانها ضخ المزيد من الغاز لأوروبا
لكن ذلك قد يحتاج أشهر من التطوير وربما سنوات،
لكنها لن تستطيع أن تعوض الغاز الروسي
لوحدها أبدا، بحسب المسؤولين الجزائريين.
(ماذا بعد التهديد؟)
دانت كوريا الشمالية بشدة تصريحات
وزير الدفاع الكوري الجنوبي بشأن قدرة
بلاده توجيه ضربات إلى الشمال،
وحذرت انها ستستهدف أهداف رئيسية
في سيول إذا قامت كوريا الجنوبية
بأعمال عسكرية
ونقلت وكالة الأنباء المركزية الكورية الشمالية
عن كيم يو جونغ شقيقة زعيم كوريا الشمالية
كيم جونغ أون قولها في بيان إن تصريحات
وزير الدفاع الكوري الجنوبي سوه ووك
"أدت لتفاقم سوء العلاقات بين الكوريتين
والتوتر العسكري في شبه الجزيرة الكورية
(فهل يستفز جنوب شبه الجزيرة الكورية
شمالها وتندلع حرب جنونية؟)
(ليبيا تطلب ود بوتين)
رئيس الوزراء الليبي المؤقت عبدالحميد الدبيبة
يلجأ لزعيم الشيشان في معركته
مع باشاغا.. الدبيبة يعيد تنشيط قنوات الاتصال
مع زعيم الشيشان للتقرب من بوتين،
لتشكيل قوات حرس خاص وتدريب
قوات ليبية في الشيشان..
(الأحداث والتطورات)
أمريكا تلغي تجربة صاروخها الباليستي،
لتخفيف التوترات النووية مع روسيا
قال سلاح الجو الأمريكي الجمعة إن الجيش الأمريكي
ألغى تجربة لصاروخه الباليستي العابر للقارات
مينيتمان 3 بعد أن كان قد أعلن في البدء
إرجاؤها في محاولة لتخفيف التوترات النووية
مع روسيا في ظل الحرب في أوكرانيا.
لكن واشنطن عبرت على الملأ عن نيتها
تأجيل التجربة فقط "لبعض الوقت" لا أن تلغيها.
أمريكا تطالب الخليج بزيادة إنتاج النفط
لكن الموقف الخليجي لم يتغير بعد
فهم يرفضون أن يكونوا طرفا
في الصراع الروسي الأمريكي..
بعد تهديدات بوتين، دول البلطيق
توقف استيراد الغاز الطبيعي من روسيا
وتعلن اعتمادها على الغاز المخزن تحت الأرض
في لاتفيا، فهل يكفي ذلك؟
روسيا تعلن عزمها تصدير الغذاء للدول
الصديقة فقط وأضافت موسكو
أن الدفع سيكون بالروبل الروسي
أو بعملات الدول المستوردة،،
هذا من شأنه أن يسبب أزمة غذاء عالمية
وارتفاعاً حاداً في أسعار القمح
الذي تعتبر روسيا وأوكرانيا
من أكبر مصدريه للعالم
المستشار الألماني أولاف شولتس يدعو بوتين
إلى الموافقة على وقف إطلاق النار
ماكرون: مايحدث في أوكرانيا يرتقي إلى مستوى
جرائم حرب
وطالب ماكرون بفرض حُزمةِ
عقوباتٍ إضافية على روسيا
وكل من تورط بجرائم الحرب في أوكرانيا
يجب أن يدفع الثمن
روسيا تحشد قواتها نحو مركز الحرب إقليم دونباس،..
زيلينسكي يدعو روسيا لسحب قواتها
قبل الدخول في محادثات مباشرة مع بوتين
ويقول أن أوكرانيا مستعدة لبحث الضمانات
الأمنية مع موسكو بعد الحرب
الدفاع الروسية تعلن تدمير ٣ مخازن وقود
ومصفاة نفط قرب أوديسا
إدارة بايدن وحلفاؤها سينقلون دبابات
سوفييتة الصنع لدونباس بهدف دعم دفاعات
أوكرانيا
البنتاغون: أمريكا تقدم ٣٠٠مليون دولار
للمساعدة الأمنية في أوكرانيا
وتشتمل هذه المساعدات على طائرات انتحارية
من طراز Switchblade وأنظمة
مضادة للطائرات بدون طيار ومدرعات
ومعدات للرؤية الليلية وذخيرة.
الرئيس الشيشاني رمضان قديروف:
قواتنا بدأت في اقتحام ماريوبول ولن يتركوا
الإرهابيين على قيد الحياة،
إيغور كوناشينكوف الناطق باسم الدفاع الروسية
يعلن تدمير نحو ٧٠ منشأة عسكرية أوكرانية،
وقال كوناشينكوف أن قواتهم ستواصل تدمير
البنية التحتية العسكرية الأوكرانية بحسب تعبيره
قال المسؤولون الأمريكيون إن الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين يتعرض لضغوط لإثبات قدرته
على تحقيق النصر في التاسع من مايو،
وشرق أوكرانيا هو المكان الذي من المرجح
أن يكون فيه قادرًا على القيام بذلك بسرعة.
٩ مايو هو اليوم الذي تحتفل فيه البلاد
باستسلام النازيين في الحرب العالمية الثانية
باستعراض ضخم للقوات والأسلحة
عبر الميدان الأحمر أمام الكرملين
روسيا تنفي قتل المدنيين في بوتشا،
وقالت وزارة الدفاع الروسية أن الصور
والتسجيلات الأوكرانية بشأن مزاعم بحدوث
انتهاكات في بوتشا عمل استفزازي
واستعراض أوكراني جديد ووصفت الصور
والفيديوهات بأنها مفبركة،
وأضافت أن المناطق الجنوبية في بوتشا
تعرضت في وقت سابق لقصف أوكراني
بأسلحة ثقيلة
وكانت  وزارة الدفاع الأوكرانية
قد  اتهمت القوات الروسية التي كانت تسيطر
على بوتشا بتنفيذ إعدامات وارتكاب مذبحة
في صفوف السكان.
ديمتري بيسكوف: المستوردون الأوروبيون للغاز
الروسي يمكنهم الاستمرار في دفع عائداته باليورو،
لكن سيتوجب عليهم أيضا فتح حسابات بالروبل
في روسيا لتحويل العائدات بالروبل إلى غاز بروم.
أعلنت قيادة القوات الجوية الأوكرانية،
إسقاط مقاتلتين روسيتين من طراز
سوخوي-34، وسوخوي-35،
إضافة لصاروخين من نوع كروز
وطائرة مروحية وإصابة طائرة للمراقبة
الجوية خلال الساعات الـ24 الماضية.
الغرب يحاول مع الصين لثنيها ويقترب
من الجزائر لتعوضهم عن موسكو
وكيم جونغ يحذر جيرانه والخليج
لا يدري ما الذي عليه فعله،
فهل تعد كل هذه مؤشرات لأزمة عالمية خانقة؟